Ukrainian president Zelensky turned 45
on Wednesday
and got one of his biggest
birthday wishes
when President Biden
announced that the United States
would send 31
M1 Abrams tanks to help with the fight.
Dozens more leopard tanks
will come from Germany and other allies.
Ukraine had long been pleading
for such heavy weapons from the West.
And this breakthrough came
after what seemed to be a game of chicken
between the United States and Germany
to see who would offer their tanks.
First,
let's talk about the war
and much more with today's terrific
global panel.
Anne-Marie Slaughter
is the former director of policy
planning at the State Department
and joins us from Princeton.
She is the president of New America.
Carl Bildt is a former prime
minister of Sweden
and joins us from Stockholm.
And Kishore
Mahbubani is a former
top Singaporean diplomat
and joins us from Singapore.
Anne-Marie, what do you make of this,
particularly the
German decision
Well, the German decision
is extraordinary
in just historical terms,
because, once again,
German tanks, Panzers.
Do most of the Russians
and the Europeans
will be fighting Russia.
They will not be rolling into Russia,
or at least we certainly hope not.
So the kind of historical significance
is enormous.
Really, though,
what's most important about this
decision is political.
It is signaling to Putin, no,
we are not going to split,
we're going to maintain cohesion
and we're going to amp up.
So we're not scared
of your threats of escalation.
That's a more important signal right now
than the actual military advantage.
It's going to take months
for the Ukrainians
to get them and to be able to use them
longer term.
It will help Ukraine defend
and actually advance against Russia,
but that's going to take quite a while.
So for now,
it's really a very important political
signal that NATO's holding together.
But Karl, if it is an important
political signal,
does it break
the stalemate
that seems to have developed
on the ground?
There is no, no,
no major advances on either side.
Will this change that
over time?
It might,
but as Anne-Marie said,
that's going to take quite some time.
I think the immediate
significance is primarily the political,
and I think it was very important
that there were you as thanks as well.
I think that is
in terms of political signal,
even more important than
the German tanks.
That might be one leopards,
which militarily is significant.
But the fact that there are some problems
is also significant.
That is going to take some months at best
to make sort of effective
fighting units out of this.
And that will make it more possible
for the Ukrainians first
to resist the new Russian offensive
that is going to come
at some point in time.
And then perhaps to be able to we control
take back
some of the territory
that Russia is trying to steal from them.
Kishore,
do you think that this play pushes Russia
in a direction
where it is more likely to negotiate?
So far, President Putin has not seemed
particularly willing to negotiate
Well, clearly,
the war has to be condemned.
Russia's invasion has to be condemned.
But I think Russia is also aware
that 85% of the world's population
has not imposed sanctions on Russia.
And if you look at it functionally,
in terms of Russia's
links with the rest of the world,
they haven't been that badly damaged
by the war.
So I don't think the
supply of additional weapons is going
to change everything
at the end of the day.
It has to be a political compromise.
And I think the vast
majority of the world would like to see
some kind of political compromise
to end the war,
because the war
is damaging all of us, too.
What do you say to that, Anne-Marie?
Is there a compromise
to be had in other words,
some kind of deal where,
let's say
Crimea is what is given to the Russians
and in return for that, Russia recognizes
most of Ukraine.
I mean, we you know,
diplomats can work out the formula.
But the question is,
is that kind of political deal?
The the the only way to end this war
I see no sign of that.
I mean, yes,
we can all outline
different possible deals.
But in fact,
the Ukrainian position has hardened
and expanded.
I mean, wanting now
really total victory, wanting
not just the Donbas back,
but also Crimea.
And I see no face-saving way
for Putin to climb down.
The certainly the stalemate
militarily means
both sides can stick to their demands.
The more doing things like sending tanks
helps Putin with his domestic audience
because his view is this is a narrow
proxy war against Russia.
So the more narrow does,
the stronger he get.
So I don't see the actual psychologic
political conditions
more or the military ones
that make
any kind of deal likely
for the foreseeable future.
Carl, where does this go?
It does sound like
I think Russia is right
that the Russians Putin seems
to have settled down for a long war
and essentially destroying
Ukrainian civilian infrastructure,
hoping to effectively defeat
the Ukrainian nation
rather than the army.
Well, I think that's correct.
Putin has tied
his entire political future
to the success
of getting rid of Ukraine,
which is what he wants to sort of restore
a greater Russian empire
that was there in the past
that he sees
as his destiny talks about life
and the death struggle.
And there is no sign of him backing down
and there is no sign of the Ukrainians
to surrender.